did your parents ever tell you like like
an old folk tale or something to get you
to do something as a kid i don't know
like i don't know i don't know what
japanese things there are
because in thailand it's like one of the
things is um if you
eat on the bed then
when you're reincarnated in your next
life you're going to reincarnate as a
snake
and i'm just remembering this now
i'm down shut me up yeah and that was
what i was told to
not get me to eat on the bed and i don't
i guess it works because i hate eating
on the bed now
japan has is like infamous for all these
like proverbs and wives tales like one
of them was like
if you sleep immediately after you eat
then you turn into a cow
oh i think thailand has something
similar to that as well
i guess i think my mum stopped telling
me this because whenever my mum told me
them i would immediately go and try them
because i i just don't i just as a kid i
just never believed anything people told
me well
i get that people would be like don't
walk under ladders or some
i just kept opening it in japanese and
nothing happened yeah
i was like well that's the thing it's
like some japanese proverbs are based on
like
actual like facts that are harmful to
your body like so
the sleeping after you eat thing is
actually has a little bit of logic to it
because like if you do sleep immediately
after you eat then all the gastric
stuff goes up your esophagus and it why
they make me so damaged your esophagus
and like
damages your throat so i'm like oh okay
so there's actual reasoning behind that
that's good but then there are some
which just like
i reserve them don't whistle at night
because snakes will come and i'm like
snakes are
literally death oh that sounds amazing
no he is
naked how snake charm was there they
don't it doesn't from the music it's
from the movement
yeah from the vibrations yeah right the
movements it's literally the movement of
this yeah the movement of the guy that
they follow
how did snake charms like start like
like they just wake up one day they're
like you know what
i want to charm some snakes i
i don't know do snape charmers even
exist anymore
i you don't really charm them do you
just make them dance a little bit right
but like is that like
a thing that's like is there a person
out there somewhere in the world that's
like yes i am a professional snake charm
probably it's probably a mouth breather
why why you're obsessed with that word
now that you've told me it is
if there's [ __ ] psychics out there
that can be any job i don't really give
a [ __ ] i just feel though it's like one
of those
like pseudo occupations that were kind
of very timely back in that
it's like you know like a soothsayer
right like no one goes around being like
i'm a professional soothsayer
they're just like saying they're just
like budget magicians yeah what is that
actually a suit say is like a person who
goes around or like tells fortunes and
like tells your future and stuff oh
that's literally [ __ ] i mean like a
fortune teller like kind of yeah
that's an occupation sounds way cooler
that that that's an occupation that
should have gone out of business
i think it did go out they're fortune
telling unfortunately yeah how that
should still exist
i don't know i i have friends who do who
do that and i'm just like you're a
[ __ ] idiot oh really
yeah with like the what the crystal ball
or the tarot cards
yeah i'm like have you seen some of the
fish out there
like do you think god really gave enough
of a [ __ ] to worry about right putting
[ __ ] inscriptions on your hand of
what your life's gonna be like men
couldn't even finish half the [ __ ]
fishes in the ocean
are you serious bro come on no no he did
not he did not inscribe he didn't give a
[ __ ] about you
i mean i like doing it every now and
then just to see what they say
it we like to feel interesting as people
yeah that's an egotistical need that we
have
but i genuinely believe that we are not
interesting things
it is up to us to make our own lives
interesting and horoscopes and all that
and all that nonsense i just don't
believe in any of it because i'm like
nobody gave gives a [ __ ] about this you
don't believe in like star signs or
anything like that no
honestly i don't yeah me neither
[Laughter]
like the whole like the whole blood yeah
cold blood type the whole uh lines on
your hands all of that [ __ ] i believe i
just think it's [ __ ] nice
i think it's cool and i and when someone
tells me i'll listen i think it's cool
for the sake of entertainment
yeah i i i view as more just like an
entertaining thing as or like a
conversation starter right yeah yeah
yeah it's not something i take seriously
but i'm like is your life so [ __ ]
boring well this is the sound that gets
you excited this is what you look
forward to
like you need you need lies to tell
yourself to to to feel like you're doing
something in life
don't [ __ ] do something some people
need that man some people need that
encouragement
wow stop go and do something stop
reading your [ __ ] hands
only mouth breathers do that
the reason why you have no chin is not
because of a lying in your hand okay
it's because
[ __ ] [ __ ] reading your hands but please
breathe through your mouth yeah that's
real
i i i think that you could like there is
behavior that you can do that can affect
your health and your body yeah yeah
that's that's i feel like that's fair to
say
yeah i mean like i think that no no
mystical entity decided to carve some
[ __ ] lines in your hand and that
would decide how your personality was
gonna be no [ __ ] no
i mean yeah there is there is a clear
difference because i feel like there is
a lot of little things you just
don't know about your body and then you
don't figure it out until you hit like
30 or something yeah and then you
realize oh
we also don't know a lot of stuff about
the human body we have like we're still
like barely understanding how the mind
works you know
yeah yeah yeah i mean we we're still
like [ __ ]
decades or centuries off to like
figuring out how that works but in terms
of
all of america doesn't even have bidets
so how the [ __ ] are they gonna have
scientific breakthroughs yeah
i don't believe it you
they haven't discovered anything about
the brain um no it's just like
part of like growing up and growing into
like your 30s i guess is just realizing
that
sometimes you just have a problem with
your body and like as a kid i thought
everything's fixable everything will go
back to you yeah
and then you don't realize that
sometimes you just have a problem and
then you just
you just learn to live with it i guess
it's pretty sad
like it's like kind of hope that you
don't get a problem that's toons
yeah yeah like kidney stones [ __ ] if i
get those [ __ ]
oh yeah like everyone everyone around my
age
just starts talking about their knees
and luckily enough i haven't felt it
anything about my knees yet but
lower back pain knees like neck pain
headaches it's just it's just like god
decided all right everyone gets a debuff
at 30.
everyone gets a different one you know
it's like the moment you turn 30 just
god comes to your sleep it just clocks
you in the knees
it's like you're 30 now